[Music]
i went to california instead of the art
institute of the arts california college
what is that like what's the california
arts like it's it's close by it's it's a
great school i feel like is that their
motto we're close by
that's on the crest of the school in
latin we are close by that's that's like
the restaurant version of you get a lot
why not yeah um no it's a great school i
feel like i talk about it a lot so i
always want to preface it by saying that
it's wonderful i got a great education
there it's also very
liberal and at the time that i was there
it was especially liberal liberal and
ways like
clothing is optional everywhere
except the cafeteria which i think is a
really good policy because the last
thing you want when you're like at the
salad bar yeah yeah we know
testicles you no no
that's never what i order
well clearly we're not from the same
city uh
i well first of all i don't know how
much you're exaggerating are you being
serious when you say it's really
clothing optional at this school i mean
i don't know now if it's changed but
when i was there well by the pool
obviously you'd want clothing to be
optional and then i just think i don't
even go with that i
i come from the very repressed northeast
and
and it's also freezing cold but there's
no taking off of clothes anywhere not
even before you shower and you have the
option if you had the option
no i did not no i would not inflict my
body on people
i would be very happy for other people
to take their clothes off but i would
not follow you i think that as a policy
they do it more for performance like so
that people if they're like you know
it's an art school so people are doing
impromptu performances like around and
then you could do that but i would use
it more for
comedy purposes be nude now i understand
that's something i can relate to be nude
for comics when i'm when i'm naked it is
for comedic purposes yes yes yes so like
every now and then i would just throw on
my tennies and like take a jaunt through
like not all the time but just once in a
while you exercise my right
you'd put on sneakers and you would jog
naked through the campus yes really yeah
are there
thank you
thank you
thank you for your support where is this
school exactly
and how late are they open
no i'm serious that just absolutely
fascinates me well
or like i said for comedy it would be it
would be you know like if my roommate
was having a bad day and i wanted to
make her laugh to feel better i would
sort of pretend like i was gonna go take
a shower but then i would sneak outside
and like hang from the tree outside our
window
like a monkey like a naked monkey like
naked well monkeys are always naked uh
exactly yeah so that but but but that's
very i just can't believe you would
really do that and is this accepted at
that school i mean people are people are
walking by like oh ho hum there's a
naked lady in a tree
swinging around i think so that is very
strange they never reacted too too
crazily to my nudity that's very strange
andy was there new to me at your school
uh
you know no not i mean i guess there was
some like streaking kind of things but
not like no nobody hanging from a tree
and you said a naked lady
a lady in a tree that's nude is not a
lady whoa whoa
i'm just kidding these are [ __ ] words
these are getting a break you two should
fight naked
this didn't happen if it were absolutely
yes
you still got a good education there
didn't you i did what kind of classes
did you take at this naked school well
aside from our theater classes i was a
theater major and those classes were
excellent
but
the general ed classes could be very
interesting you sort of had this feeling
i thought that they people were just
making them up at random like the ufo
class
um what's what would happen what would
they teach you in the ufo class i never
got to take it because it was always
full like that was the first class
people would sign up for there was also
but i did take a class called um queer
books
and it may not still be a class they
change every year and basically we would
read the classics if you will and then
just talk about how the characters were
gay so like
so like we just read like sherlock
holmes and he'd be like watson
yay
and you'd be like
he is and he'd be like a
well we didn't we didn't get a's b's or
c's that's a fantastic i mean that just
sounds like every paper then is just
whatever you read no matter what you
read was just oh we read moby dick queer
yeah you'd be like hello title alone
yeah that's so strange yeah it was
a lot of innuendo involved in the papers
that we would write but it was more like
you'd find clues like once you put on
the gay goggles anybody can be gay
it you know
where do you get these don't look at me
i don't mind yeah you know
look all you want yeah
fine